I gotta have music it would have to be
music first and foremost I got like six
thousand songs on my ipod I would bring
a guitar because I play music and I
think that would kind of chill me out
and distract me
that would be so depressed if I didn't
have some way to play music so like a
really stocked iPod or something with me
I would write like five thousand songs
some sort of delicious food item not
much unlike in the movie we had these
fluffernutter sandwiches that are being
made that were a sandwich from my
childhood if I could have some
connection to the outside world in terms
of like nature if I could have some
plants or like some sort of flower that
I could keep alive or something I've
never read any of the Harry Potter books
but my mom and my sister are obsessed
with them so I take those I'd cross that
off my list it would be video games
custom sort of video game console I want
to take a comic book collection some of
my underground comics I used to read
them over and over and over
my old man magazines probably some
movies too they would be movies I've
always wanted to get really good at pool
I'm not really good at shooting pool and
I'd like to become a pool shark so I'd
see if I could bring a pool table down
if it was big enough if I could have a
dog or a cat or something well there's a
cats not cats but something that feels
like a friend down there would be really
helpful
you